[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
青木と申します
今私は同社でまぁ講義をしております
と同時にですねまあ裏な顔がありまして
キリスト教会で牧師をしております
今日はちょっとそういったことを踏まえながらですね私たちの心ということについて
考えてみたいなというふうに思います
まあそうは言いましても何か皆さんに私の信じている宗教押し付けようとかですね
そういったことではありません
私たち日本人がよくまあ耳にすると言いますか
まあほぼこういう言葉やフレーズっていうのを聞いたことがない人はいないんじゃない
かと思うような言い回しがあるのをご存知でしょうか
新聞やテレビやそしていろいろな雑誌なのにおいてもよくそういう言葉がいわれますし
それを聞いた時皆がうんいいねってこう思う言葉です
それは何かと言いますと
自分らしくとか自分を信じてっていう言葉です
例えば自分たちの自分らしくこう
スポーツので協議をしてそして勝利したいですとか自分たちのサッカーや自分たちの
野球
まあなく見るんですけどもそれをしてそしてあの勝利できました
っていうような自分らしく生きたい
このようなことを我々は聞いたり口にしたりすることがあると思います
また自分を信じて
何か今日ですねあの子の同社でも推薦入試の試験会場だということでちょっとをそうか
と思ったんですけども
受験生に対してまあ学校の先生や塾の先生や
また王子の方がですねあなた自分の今までやってきたことを信じてみましょうね自分を
信じていきましょうとかそういうことを口にしたり
聞く我々はそういったことにとしてあぁ
ガンバ
てるなって思う
これは恐らく日本人であるならばいやもしかしたら日本にだけでない世界の人々にとっ
ても非常に耳障りの良い言葉ではないかなと思います
しかし一方で
今からもう10年以上前からでしょうか
こういう言葉が色々と
新聞やメディアなど音においても
裁かれてきていますそしてこのパワー花
セクハラマタハラ赤鼻このなんとかハラハラ払ってもですね
今ではおばハラーとかいろんな言い方でどんどんハラスメントが増えてきています
つまりこれは左飛コツは違って自分らしく
いやいやそんな後の考えじゃなくて私の言うとおりにしなさいとかもしくはあなたの
その心情というのはどうでもいい
私のこの考えをちゃんと理解しなさいみたいな形で実は先ほどとは全く違う
そして自分
にたちというものを否定して大きなもっと大きな
その歯車の中に入ってきなさいみたいなことを言われるわけです
特に魔境和光大学ですから学生さんの形見と思いますけれども私たちこの日本の社会と
いうのはどうも学生時代までは自分を信じなさい
自分のやりたいと思うことや夢を持ちなさい
このように言いますが
おそらく3回生の終わりの3月の1日はぐらいから髪の毛も真っ黒に染まり
そしてスーツの黒くなると同時にですねいつしか
社会に出るとあなたの考えではダメですよ
あなたのその考え方ということだけでこのようなたはできていません
いいよって言うこういう相対するメッセージを受け取ってしまうようになってしまうん
じゃないかなと思います
この矛盾っていうのを今ここで解決はできないと思います
しかし今日私は皆さんに一つそのあのひとつの知恵としてお伝えしたいことがあります
それはこの現実の中に矛盾したメッセージがある
これをどうにかす事ができません
しかしこの矛盾というものを受け止めつつ自分を
信じて生きるそういう方法ってないんだろうかな私は実はそういうことをずっとずっと
考え続けてき
います
その時に一つ前提となっているものがあります
何かといったら私たちは生まれてそしてそのままでは成長できないってことです
つまり4 a 8
知識というものを受けることによって私たちは大きくなっていきますしいろんなことが
理解できるようになっていきます
多くの場合人間っていうのはこのような知性とか
そして体力においてはこういう反復し何度もですね腹筋をしたりですね
もしくは計算問題を解いたりとかしながら自分を鍛えていくということは
します
しかし日本のこの今の教育の制度の中において一つ重大なものが欠けていると言わ
なければなりません
何かといったそれは
心を鍛えるって事です
むしろ心っていうのに対して私たちどう思っているかといったら何もしないで
そのままの方がいいと思い込んでいます
かく言う私も今年数は50歳になりました
そしてですねやはりどう見てもおっさんだなぁと思う部分がありますが
しかし心の中ではいつまでもあの重大だ
いつまでもあのようにこう t のように何て事を思う
そう思うこと自体が3もおっさんだと思いますけれども
でも何か心だけは
何も手に触れない人のて赤をつけない
そして何かそのままもしくは少年のまま少女のままのほうがより純粋でピュアでいいん
だという思い込みです
実は
心も
人間の中では立派な期間
つまり
いざとか心臓とかもしくは筋肉と同じように鍛えることができるということです
そして
その着替えるっていう時に心においてはなんといってもやっぱり異なる世界観に触れる
ことが重要だろうと思います
今までの自分の知っている世界そういうものから
一方でていくことです私は今日ここにこういう丸いですね
あの園が中にこういますここからもしも一方
いてはどうなのかなと思うんですけれども私たちはいつしかそういうのがあったがその
中で話をしなきゃいけない
もしくは私たちの中では高校生とはこういうもの
大学生とかこういうもの社会人とはこういうもの40代とはこういうものみたいなそう
いう世界観を持っています
しかし
異なる全く違う世界観に触れるという体験をしたときに人はどうもーかといったら
びびっちゃいます
思わず身構えてしまうでしょ
しかし自分よりも大きな存在
それに向き合うという経験を何度かすることを通して
実は自分というものをに対して常にアップデートできるっていうこういう効果こういう
風にして心というのは鍛えていくという方法があります
その時に
この自分よりも大きな存在といってもぼんやりしてますよね色んなものがあると思い
ます
今日私は皆さんにその中の一つを提示してみたいと思いますそれは宗教というものです
私が牧師だから出たかと思たかもしれませんが違うんです
今日私が皆さんにお伝えしたいことは
宗教を利用してごらんなさいということです
まあテイスティングと言ってもいいかもいません自分が気に入ったものを子
つまんでみたらどうですか
結構日本人の真面目ですから一つの宗教というものに触れたらそれ以外のもに増えこと
はいけないとか何かこれを信じたらそれ以外でも全部捨てて
に思ってしまいがちですがそうではない
いろんなものをテイスティングしてみてはどうですか
そのことを今日はお伝えしたいと思います
しかし日本人
多くの場合宗教は怖いと思っています
おそらくそうでしょう私がもしもここで
教会できているような洋服を着てですね皆さん校門の前とかでこうなんか変だっけの
いかがわしいチラシを配っていたらですておそらくタイムってこないと思います
なぜかといったらそれは特に日本人の私たちにとっての世界観というものとおそらく
宗教っていうのがあまりにも縁遠いからだと思います
私もあまりイスラームとか
また様々なヒンズー教とかそういったことはあまりわかりません
世界観が異なっているときに人はそこで恐怖を覚えてしまう
それはあるかも知れませんしかしこの怖いっていう着るとちょっとおいて実はもう少し
自分っていうものをしっかりと見つめ直す
モードしてトライときに実は宗教というのは1000人た
の知恵の集積であるということができます
宗教は先人たちが作り上げてきた
そして矛盾してどう考えてもおかしいって思うその中を生きなければいけないと思う時
に生み出して編み出したひとつの知恵です
その集積が実は今の宗教という形になっている
宗教には当然アピールポイントがあります
こういったことを信じてくださいとかこういったところ素晴らしいでしょという
ポイントがあります
でも皆さん私たちは宗教を信じる必要はない
でも宗教教える必要はあります
矛盾している現実を生きていくための指針としてその宗教が与えている
その部分を本質をもしつかむことができるならばそういったものに触れることができる
ならばそれは私たちを生かす知恵になっていきます
まあ宗教というのはこのように競技とか二色とか擁護っていうような独自の世界観を
持っています
しかしその特に言葉とか
その儀式が何であるんですかどうしてそうなんですかなんでそのように言うんですか
っていう風にしてそれを解体していくことができるならばその中に知恵ができます
それが私にとってキニーもうであったりもしくはそれがいいなって思うんだったらその
知恵を自分のものにすればいいだけのことです
ちょっと話がずれかもしれないけども
しかし宗教と言ったらいわゆるカルド的なものがあると言われています
でかつ的なものと私が今行っている宗教というものとの違いは何でしょうか
実はこの
独自の世界観を持っているそういった
擁護とか儀式的なものっていうものを別の言葉に言い換えてくださいっていう時に
その言い換えということを禁じるもしそういう教えだとしたらそれはおそらく危ないと
思います
これは真理なんです真理はもうこれ以上支えられません
とかそれは摂理なんですとそこには大いなる力が働いてとか言ってですね
それ以上の言葉に変えることができないとしたら
それは
危ない
逃げた方がいい
宗教胚葉から間違いありません
私たちはさまざまな異なる宗教というもの
そこからいろいろな刺激を受けるときにそれを教えとして受け止めていくとき
その中でいつしか私たちがその6集してどう考えても理屈からいっても法律からいって
もおかしいでも私たちの車内にはとか私たちのこの人間関係の中にはあるその矛盾
それを乗り越えていくためには強くならなきゃっていうその知恵を宗教を与えてくれ
ます
そしてそれが与えられることによって実はあ
乗り越えられた一つその子の中で自分の人間関係をうまく築くれた
それが信じられる自分を作っていきます
そのような働きというものを通して信じられる自分がどんどんと作り上げられていく
ならば
例えば
先ほど見たようなこういう様々ないわゆる
ハラスメント
ないとは言いませんおそらくあるでしょうもしくはしたら日常3時かもしれません
でもそれに対してそれをきちっと乗り越える
解決する
そういう術まで行き方
自分の持ちようというものをしっかりと
理解できますと同時にもう一つ
1件
ハラスメントかのように思うんですけれども実はその人が言わんとすることの中に本当
は自分を活かす知恵だってあるかもしれないんですよね
昨今ではハラスメント話す目に撮ったことはどんどんどんどん増えてきますからすると
本当は大事なことを
もしくは私たちを生かすような知恵であったとしても
それがもうあの人私に何だかハラスメントしたってことで切ってしまったら本当に信じ
られる自分をつくっていく
その
瞬間そのチャンスを失ってしまうことにもなりかねません
ですから
異なる世界観に自分が取り込まれてしまうって思うんじゃなくてそこから自らを育む
知恵を得るのだ
こういう視点に立つことで
実は私たちは成長をするそして心を鍛えていく
さらに自分が信じられるようになっていきます
ハラスメントプロが一番何が辛いかといったら自分はそう思ってないのに相手がそう
いうから相手のいう欲はキャラン理論梨央奈て自分も入ってしまうということが一番
怖い
辛い
まさに異なる世界観に取り込まれてしまうことが怖いんです
宗教というのはそういう意味において最適なサンプリングダイザー
の
題材です
私たちがそのことをしっかりと掴むならば私は今日ある意味声を大にして申し上げたい
皆さん宗教を利用してください
宗教家が言うから間違いありません宗教を利用することによって心は鍛えられていき
ますありがとうございました
[拍手]